let's say that for the rest of time yeah
you only had 10 exercises MH to hold on
to and grow as much muscle as you
could what would you choose and why
incline uh incline presses no question
about it dumbbell uh dumbbell more than
likely because you know it's just you
can do a lot with the dumbbells over the
barbell
right um I always want that shelf up
here it looks great in t-shirts and uh
yeah you know if you're hitting a side
shot you want the upper PEC development
to exist there's something about that
angle that's so comfortable as well yeah
it feels so it feels right yeah feels
right yeah you don't feel as much in
danger yep in my opinion even when
you're doing flies you know like you
can just it just feels so good you know
so that would be one of them side
laterals for sure dumbbell lateral Rays
standing seated standing for sure and
where do you what were your cues on this
I knew you were going to say this yeah
from the to the side are you out in
front a little bit here what you
thinking to the side y to the side are
you leading with elbows leading with
arms uh more just I guess that would
just be with arms right you so because
sometimes you see people almost flaring
up with dumbbells down but as you did
that your traps moved yep so I don't
need that y I don't want that lower trap
now that's gonna uhuh I just need to get
it if I'm working this I understand it's
a secondary muscle but I don't need to
be you're isolating because you end up
doing this you see guys like they come
now and then they're doing this you see
it why is that moving can I deactivate
it sure right here okay cool let's do
that so okay
oh one armed
preachers one on preacher curls
dumbbells again it could be on a machine
or dumbbells you know but but since
we're going to you know only have some
dumbbells on a deserted island we're
going to do that you can use whatever
you want this is you got the best gym in
in history but you can only use 10
preacher curl um and why single because
I can concentrate more on one arm than
two mhm um I can also isolate and
understand why is one's arm stronger
than the other and am I performing the
rep the same on either arm now if I'm in
a fixed position I can't tell so I need
to see I need to feel and I need to
physically see this so are you suating
on that or are you going to St oh yeah
I'm going to do that but I also got to
recognize like am I having any uh you
know bicep tendon stuff and like
that and um which I actually have right
now I'm like damn like okay it yeah yeah
yeah you know that's three so that's
three uh hack squats for
sure for sure hack squats oh my gosh it
just feels incredibly strong to be in
that position I love it
it's yeah I I did a lot of damage on
that machine um what are your cues when
doing hack
squat well you know the
platform I can go wide I can go at the
top I can go at the bottom I can go
narrow you know I like to go a little
bit you can have that that can be all
part of four that can yeah exactly see
but it's all the system you playing the
system okay so that's full okay this is
fun
um rear
delts uh but but uh face pulls with the
uh with the with the Rope okay I love
that yeah around about ey height yeah uh
yeah right right here
yep um you know since we're using that
rope you know tricep
extensions
overhead down okay yep yep so that's
what six six four
okay four
more we got to throw another chest
movement in there so
um I mean we did the in incline dumbbell
press we got to have an incline dumbbell
fly um why put both of those in what are
you getting out of the fly you're not
get getting a good stretch and I'm able
to contract you know differently as well
working that same plane um reults what
about back we got to throw some back in
there so underhand barbell uh uh Rose
underhand bent over bent over Rose
underhand y um what's your reason for
going underhand rather than overhand
then um because I've noticed that
overhand I'm getting more of I'm
initially you're going to feel it more
in your forearms right here yep and I'm
only going to get so much and I feel
like it's more like I'm going to there's
more margin for error I believe whereas
if you're coming here I don't feel it as
much and it's simulating what I would do
on stage P pulling the elbows back so
would you do uh I guess a part of that
as well is restricting the uh injury
risk from being bent over so much like
underhand you're always going to be a
little weaker so would you do that from
a rack rather than from the floor oh
I've done that from the four right yeah
I've done that from the four a lot of
axial loads being at that angle your
lower back but it's much less than a
deadlift I suppose yeah but you
sometimes you can go to like a squat
rack and then it'll have like the little
bars there so you can pull so you get
safety bars so you just pull it off of
that cool okay I think you've got two
left so I got two left oh
boy what have we got let's recap so we
got the incline you got incline dumbbell
incline fly Lal you have lateral raises
you have hack squats you have single AR
uh preacher push push down face PS and
then spent over underhand you know what
I'm going to go with
pull-ups um neutral underhand overhand
overhand overhand
wide and I guess last one would be
another
legs
stepmill you can use the stepmill is the
10th exercise and did you we I can carve
out the legs I
can you know I can I can do glutes with
that did you ever do that
weighted yeah actually I did I wore a
weight vest for what show was that it
was early in my career I wore like
weight vest and I wear like ankle
weights and I did something that no one
else ever did I was using um eastem
units while I was doing cardio like a
compex yeah I used compex cuz I was
sponsored by them for a while so I was
doing compacts on step mill dude anyone
that thinks that uh electric stem
training is not like put a an sp6 or an
sp8 on you and turn turn it up to 25%
and try and do a squat an air squat yeah
and tell me that it's it's not absolute
agony that that would uh the only thing
I I I think
now
is like you know the neuroplasticity and
like also like neuro feedback you get by
using one of those machines I don't I
would love to be able to test that
because I think with it doing the work
kind of for you you may lose some of
that so you have to be careful I think
with um overloading it yes because you
can push it further than you push it
further than you can really do it so I
know I did that but I'm an extreme
athlete you know with that when it comes
to the stepper very very popular cardio
exercise for bodybuilders what are
people missing what are they getting
wrong when you see other people they're
holding on to the holding they're
hugging the damn
thing you know what they're also doing
by doing that they're rounding out their
back and you think about doing this
you're I mean just me doing this right
now like that doesn't seem comfortable
why not just stand
straight slow it down maybe may you know
what I'm saying maybe not have it at
five or six because I gotta and you hear
that person stomping on the damn things
if they weighed 250 pounds or something
like that you know their knees would be
shot their knees would be tor toast so
you're using control even on the so you
should you should you should you should
you should have it at level one level
two and slowly do it now it now the
reason why you won't do that ladies and
gentlemen is because it's
boring but think about how much muscle
activation you can have on that with
your uh glutes and quads with each step
actually being Purpose Driven so my
whole mentality when I would do cardio
man I'm giving y'all all the damn
Secrets
man put it like this you got to gamify
your card as much as possible so if you
could have every step count towards
something you could actually sculpt
glutes
quads and isn't that the whole point of
doing cardio or you just want to sweat
we'll get back to talking to Phil in one
minute but first I need to tell you
about factor I get asked all the time
about how to build and maintain muscle
and the most important thing the first
thing you need to do is ensure you are
getting one gram per kilo of body weight
in protein every single day but as you
know if you have ever tried to to cook
anything ever consistently you'll stick
to your Macros finding whole food
healthy meals you can have conveniently
every single day is difficult this is
where Factor comes in their fresh never
frozen meals are designed by registered
dietitians and arrive ready to heat and
eat in minutes it requires zero prep so
if you're someone that says I'd love to
hit my protein numbers but I never have
time to cook prep takes so long and I
hate doing it this is the solution for
you so if you want to make an
improvement to your diet this August you
can get factor and start eating better
without the hassle head to the link in
the description below or go to factor
meals.com
mw50 and use the code mw50 for 50% off
your first order a checkout that's
factor meals.com
mw50 and mw50 a checkout if you enjoyed
that clip with Phil then press here for
the fulllength 2hour podcast episode
when we go so deep in the history of his
career his Reflections on Generation
Iron his rivalry with Kai green the
peeds that he did and did not use go on
press
it